how do you feel about like kind of the
current state of atlanta and just like
where it is as far as like artist
integrity like i feel like atlanta still
runs this whole [ __ ] bro like yeah
um i think that uh i think it's in a
good place man i think that uh has a
decent balance you know what i'm saying
i feel like uh
the trap the trout [ __ ] or at least the
trap sound right i'm saying because it
started off as trout because [ __ ] was
talking about trap right [ __ ] now it's
just it's just the sound yeah right so
like uh
i feel like um
[Music]
even if it's if it may not have been
it's like as hard as it was like 10
years ago but it's still like the
hardest [ __ ] is
it dominates the airwaves you know i'm
saying like it's it's more friendly on
the ear now you know i'm saying like
kids can [ __ ] with it and
and everybody right muff egg 21 savage
gonna wrap his ass off amigos
literally probably the most influential
rappers in the last like decade so i saw
a [ __ ] with it bro and then on the uh
on just like the the lyrical side of
things you know just like
i feel like we all gotta
like we kind of [ __ ] with these like for
the most part everybody [ __ ] with each
other right right you know what i'm
saying in atlanta you know i'm saying
some on the lyrical [ __ ] so like like i
said like j like j.i.d like that's the
homie and [ __ ] so like you know we
talked earth gangs out there you know
kenny mason kenny mason was just here he
free stuff he's a [ __ ] beast yeah
master he's an alien you know me and
[ __ ] man so like
you know i think it's in a good spot bro